>> Jeff: JACKETS WEAR
MARCHMENT FROM THE OFFHIFTS BY E
WITH MARCHMENT, AND
AND THAT PUCK COMES FROM
MARCHMENT BEHIND, NICE PLAY BYE!
JACKETS WITH AARDS THE NET
GOOD THINGS ARE GOING TO
REBOUND, SCORES.
IT'S A POWER PLAY GOAL.HANDED S
RIGHT SIDE AND HE'S OPEN, READY
AND HE GOES UPSTAIRS.
ABOUT YOU BEST
PASSERS EVER.
>> Jeff: 2 ON 1
HOCKEY LEAGUE AND THERE'S A LOOK
AT IT.
BOONE JENNER WITH
IN.
DISHING IN FRONT   YOU KNOW, TH
WERE FORECHECKS, BIG BODIEETS!
PATRIK LAINE ALL AROUND VORACEKY
READS THEHE LONE, AND
AWAY, AND THE COUNTER IS
MARCHMENT AGAIN, THIS LINE THE
SIDE OF THE NET, AND HE'S DOMI'H
THIS.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE PUCK FOR
VERY LONG, BUT WHAT AO WITHIN O!
OH, OFF THE POSTE TO
REDIRECT IT.
HE WAS LEFT ALL ALONE PASSES IN
ONE BY BENN BROADWAY, AND FLORIA
THERE, MIDDLE OF THE ICE AND
GOESAGAIN.
WHAT A NIGHT FOR MASON
MARCHMENT, HE'S GOT VERY LITTLE
THERE AND THAT'SS